oh that's that's intelligence and touch
by the great casey jones
true champion 12-time champ casey jones
that game against milwaukee 33 in all
well remember the two precinct
preseason games were a real struggle is
kevin durant cooking early here
he had a pre-existing relationship with
kyrie irving that he was telling us
about a little bit earlier kyrie might
not have called
bank but he knows the rims and
i'm shocked that he's not in the top
three even though he's in that next
group
how many of those other three guys can
guard like that
that are above him league out front jeff
teague was a great pickup for the
celtics
and danny ainge in free agency
in nine christmas day contests
and looking to add to that total and
with deandre jordan now matched up
against marcus smart
pull up jumper got to his spot and made
it look easy that free throw line area
deandre jordan bringing some smoke
wow off a great feed that's the play
that was whistled
prior to the dunk last time you got
kyrie irving working with his good
friend
my goodness he's way up on the square
dorsey look he sure
is can you do that
picks it back out to pritchard five on
the shot clock
and he got ripped by irving dinwiddie on
the break
missed the layup not a bad start to your
season and jean morant 44
yes the young stars doing some work
irving with the steer down three putter
brooklyn on the move a deep three kyrie
in the house
at times was electric in that first half
joe harris good start for him he's got
eight
go beyond the box score for this boston
team
for the last couple of years here's
duran out top
thompson switched on to him it really
doesn't matter sometimes
k.d off glass yeah we
have chronicled doris as durant with a
mid-range jumper pure
the third quarter brooklyn down by one
but not for long
durant
[Applause]
thompson trying to stick him again and
it doesn't matter
smart on irving
they go to duran again we've got nine
quick points in the period
and an assist to jordan there
and each has taken their turn these two
guys have given their team the lead
right out of this
getting in this bag a little bit tatum
from deep
and one and done back comes kyrie irving
hits another gear and finishes with the
left
quarter like i said he's been a one-man
show with great hustle for the offensive
board
kyrie from d got it
durant he's the medicine trying to keep
it alive and here's irving
and duran and levert on the break kyrie
off glass
good you got to get a timeout here it's
getting away and brad stevens going to
use one
points are going to be tough to come by
without tatum and brown on the floor
at the same time irving with a nice step
through off glass and a feathery touch
says i could not be lebron but i loved
watching
lebron irving from deep hits the three
kyrie irving with a great moment
after their last game as durant glides
in for the reverse
layup their chemistry experiment really
has a head start
kyrie got all the way to the cup again
as nash
has had pre-existing relationships with
both kevin durant
smith the rookie switches out on to
kyrie school time
ring the bell schools in for irving
and brown with the miss irving in a rush
the time dropped to dinwiddie and
another easy bucket in transition for
brooklyn
a good moment inside that brooklyn
locker room
after they beat golden state kyrie
irving who launches another three here
and connects another three